and i took your childish laughter by
surprise bob saget's widow kelly rizzo
remembers her late husband one month
after his death the travel blogger
shares this sweet montage on instagram
full of clips of the couple enjoying
their big passion for food
in the caption kelly writes quote one
month without this incredible man bob
truly lived life to the fullest
[Music]
the 42 year old continues he had so many
hardships over the years that he would
always tell me look life is hard we need
to enjoy it as much as possible and they
did just that by exploring amazing food
around the world their happy place kelly
writes anywhere involving food
[Music]
specifically kelly says they loved
hanging out at restaurants hotel lobbies
and their kitchen at home
[Music]
the late comedian's widow shares
heartfelt memories of dining with bob
explaining that he'd always encourage
others to order everything on the menu
quote experiencing simple pleasures in
life like that brought him so much joy i
can't even put into words how much i
will miss this
[Music]
celebrities like john mayer taylor
lautner and katie couric sent their love
in the comments
but it's bob's close friend and full
house co-star candace cameron beret who
had the most emotional reaction of all
hi
i'm having a moment of grief and i just
kelly i just watched your video
um
i had such bad dreams last night
and everyone from full house was in them
bad dreams meaning
it was just
it was missing everyone and fear of
losing everyone and um and then woke up
this morning and realized it was it's
been one month so
i guess my
my heart my spirit knew that
um
just wanted to share it i guess because
it just helps when you share
e.t spoke with candace this week it's
been a rough roller coaster as anyone
knows that has grieved a loved one
it's hard to think that it's almost a
month
the actress says she's relying on her
loved ones to help her grieve
the most comforting part is
all the relationships i have with
everyone and all of us um talking like
the full house family and
kelly
bob's wife and and aubry and laura his
daughters and
and all the friends we've all been in
really close contact and um
that was strangely one of the most
unreal weeks of my life just the the
week
from the week that he passed
up into the funeral because we were all
together every day
practically 24 hours a day look
at his camera
she's my tv daughter the late actor's
family revealed on wednesday his cause
of death sharing details they learned
from the investigation
in a statement obtained by e.t the
family explains quote bob passed from
head trauma they have concluded that he
accidentally hit the back of his head on
something thought nothing of it and went
to sleep no drugs or alcohol were
involved where it is conceivable that
you know with enough
force with even a fall from standing for
someone who's you know over six foot
tall like mr saget
hitting your head against something hard
could cause uh substantial trauma
intracranially i think it's very common
in our lives we you know we we hit our
bodies against things all the time and
don't think much of it or just brush it
off and potentially with enough pressure
inside the skull
and enough pressure on the brain
could lead to coma or debt